la corse toujours paralysées par les
grèves et les manifestations
le premier ministre recevra lundi une
délégation de parlementaires municipal
second tour très politique dimanche avec
un nombre record de confrontation
triangulaire où quadrangulaire ce soir
l'exemple de dunkerque la roumanie au
ban de l'europe la commission du sel
suspendre les négociations commerciales
l'ambassadeur français rappelé en
consultations rugby français causes
demeurent au parc des princes et en
direct bien sûr sur antenne 2 le retour
musclé de la vieille garde
monsieur bonsoir ni avions ni bateau le
transports routiers paralysés les des
manifestations aujourd'hui encore la
corse continue de se crisper
après plusieurs semaines de grève dans
la fonction publique le gouvernement
aujourd'hui a réagi le premier ministre
recevra lundi à leur demande d'une
délégation de parlementaires corses et
le ministre de l'intérieur a lancé tout
à l'heure un appel au calme
nicolas jacobs ce matin dans la baie
d'ajaccio le car-ferry cyrnos prend le
large
il était retenu à quai depuis 48 heures
c'est un des rares mouvements observés
aujourd'hui sur l'île la paralysie est
maintenant presque totale
pas d'avion pas d'école pas
d'administration 90% des fonctionnaires
sont en grève d'autres catégories comme
les éboueurs des services municipaux les
marins et les pêcheurs se sont également
mises en grève toute la journée les
manifestations se sont succédé comme ici
dans les rues de bastia ou encore
ajaccio
que 500 manifestants ont pénétré dans
les jardins de l'assemblée régionale
sans heurts mais la situation reste très
tendue cet après midi le ministre de
l'intérieur pierre joxe a lancé un appel
au calme
cette situation doit trouver maintenant
une issue et les nécessaire que chacun
assume ses responsabilités reprenne son
calme et saisissent l'occasion qui
s'ouvre avec la rencontre organisée par
le premier ministre et les
parlementaires de l'île pour que la
corse reprennent toutes ses chances de
développement harmonieux dans le calme
qui lui est nécessaire
michel rocard et les parlementaires
corses doivent se rencontrer lundi à
matignon ils procéderont à un examen de
la situation de l'île mais d'ores et
déjà les syndicats préviennent qu'il n'y
aura pas de retour au calme tant que
leurs revendications ne seront pas
satisfaites
oui ces revendications françois joly
nous l'a expliqué tout au long de la
semaine ces revendications sont liées à
la cherté du coût de la vie dans l'île
même si les différences de prix restent
dans bien des cas assez mystérieuse
en toile de fond et la grogne qui s'est
généralisé dans la population le prouve
le problème sans s'exposer jamais résolu
du développement économique de l'île
nous retrouverons françoise joly quand
ils font grève
c'est toute la vie de l'île qui s'en
ressent pas simplement parce qu'ils ne
vont plus travailler que toutes les
administrations sont fermées mais parce
que leur patron l'état est le premier
employeur de l'île
ici une personne sur quatre travaillent
dans la fonction publique
l'administration est une des richesses
de l'île
la principale avant le commerce et le
tourisme pas d'industrie en corse les
seules entreprises
on les trouve dans le bâtiment la plus
importante d'entre elle emploie 250
personnes
l'agriculture elle aussi fait triste
mine
il n'y a que la vigne pour lui redonner
un peu de santé agriculture industrie
ces deux secteurs emploi seulement 10%
de la population active en corse une
économie bien mal en point avec le taux
de chômage le plus élevé de france
l'accord se trouve aujourd'hui dans un
état de non développement et on
l'expliquent par le fait que l'état ne
s'est jamais préoccupé de générer en
corse un développement ligne commis de
production
a toujours pensé qu'on pouvait régler le
problème corse par des créations
d'emplois dans la fonction publique
et pourtant si des emplois autre que
dans la fonction publique ne sont pas
créés en corse ce n'est pas faute
d'argent
cette région est une de celles qui a
toujours reçu le plus d'aidé de l'état
sans compter ces subventions spécifiques
comme cette enveloppe de 750 millions
destinés au transport entre l'île et le
continent
une subvention qui devrait réduire le
coût des marchandises en corse pour sa
plus grande part les 750 des 350
millions vont au transport de passagers
une plus faible part va au transport de
marchandises
la région dans n'a pas la maîtrise dans
la mesure où l'état lui a imposé des
compagnies concessionnaires du transport
politique professionnelle syndicalistes
tous aujourd'hui montre du doigt l'état
en revanche ils se font beaucoup plus
discret dès que l'on évoque la vie
économique ou politique de l'île
parfois bien mouvementée
avec nous des ratios l'un des
parlementaires qui rencontreront la dc
le premier ministre michel rocard il
s'agit du président du conseil général
de corse du sud
josé rossi mesure aussi bon soit cette
réunion lundi à matignon
quel sens lui d'année vous vous n'allez
quand même pas vous substituer aux
syndicats lise la fonction publique qui
sont en grève depuis plus d'un mois
pas du tout mais nous avons le devoir en
tant que parlementaire de donner à
michel rocard premier ministre
l'ensemble des données qui
conditionneront certaines de ses
décisions sur le problème de la fonction
publique car au delà de la fonction
publique qui à la situation de l'île
dans son ensemble qui est mauvaise elle
est mauvaise depuis de longues années
les gouvernements se sont succédé et
n'ont pas trouvé de réponse véritable
assez ce problème il faut si vous
admettez qu'il y à déjà des subventions
forte importants qui vont à la corse et
leur répartition passe par vous passez
par les élus alors est ce que là aussi
il n'y a qu'un pas un problème pieds là
chez vous en corse
écoutez le problème est de savoir si les
aides de l'état vont jusqu'aux
consommateurs vont jusqu'à la population
exemple avis là dessus
en l'état actuel des choses ce n'est pas
le cas pour une grande part je prends un
exemple l'aide apportée par l'état aux
transports la fameuse aide de la
continuité territoriale bien chacun sait
que sur le port de marseille et non pas
en corse
une partie importante des aides qui
devrait aller à l'allègement des tarifs
entre la corse et le continent sert à
surpayer certains intermédiaires où
certains
dockers pour dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont sur le port de marseille
est bien cela il faut peut-être y mettre
aussi bon ordre et je crois qu'il ne
faut pas faire porter à la corse la
responsabilité de tout ce qui ne va pas
nous sommes faire reconnaître nos torts
quand nous en avons mais il ya aussi un
problème d'autorité de l'état un
problème de suivi du dossier corse et
c'est ce que je voudrais dire à monsieur
rocard lundi prochain que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en corse du côté des
salariés de la fonction publique et peut
être un révélateur d'une crise beaucoup
plus vaste je le disais en commençant et
beaucoup de choses se trouvait dans la
marmite qui est en train d'exploser
alors pourquoi ne pas saisir cette
occasion pour réaliser en quelque sorte
dans une ambiance de style mai 68
aujourd'hui encore parce qu'on haneda
une sorte de grenelle corses n'ont pas
seulement sur les problèmes de la
fonction publique
mais sur l'ensemble des dossiers chauds
et nous engager d'accord entre la région
et le gouvernement dans une voie cadre
une loi programme qui pourrait être
soumise au parlement sur la corse bien
sûr avant la fin de la prochaine session
parlementaire ou au tout début de la
session de rentrée en octobre
monsieur rossi merci pour ces précisions
la délégation de parlementaires dont
vous ferez donc partie sera conduite par
le président de l'assemblée corse jean
paul de rocca c'est et reçu donc lundi
par le premier ministre
gare à l'inflation la hausse des prix à
la consommation le mois dernier a été de
0,3 pour cent mais par rapport à nos
voisins est pas si mal
gérard leclerc lee bonne ni mauvaise
surprise au ministère de l'économie on
février l'inflation a continué de
cheminée doucement notamment sur
l'alimentation les services et certains
produits manufacturés qui répercutent
les hausses sur les matières premières
et le dollar pas de dérapage néanmoins
la france reste calée sur les
performances de l'allemagne donc
relativement à l'abri des vents
inflationnistes qui souffle des deux
côtés de l'atlantique notamment aux
états unis où une flambée des prix de
gros a jeté le trouble aujourd'hui même
sur les marchés boursiers alors simple
répit disons que le pire n'est jamais
sûr surtout si les etats-unis et la
grande-bretagne maîtrisent leur
surchauffe économique
les terres bergot voie devra conjuguer
chance et vigilance pour tenir son
objectif d'une inflation limitée à 2,2
pour cent cette année
oui fortes secousses donc sur les
marchés financiers internationaux dans
la crainte d'un resserrement du crédit
avec en quelques secondes la bourse de
paris a chuté près de 3% 3% avant de
clôturer sur un recul de 1,45 pour cent
par rapport à hier dimanche après demain
second tour des municipales second tour
politiquement complexe puisque dans
beaucoup de villes de plus de 30 mille
habitants on assistera à un combat entre
trois ou même quatre listes ce qui s'est
rarement vue au delà des arbitrages que
rendront dans tel ou tel cas les
électeurs du front national ou des
écologistes
l'inconnue reste bien sûr le taux de
participation au scrutin
voyons la carte des villes chaude avec
bruno roger-petit un deuxième tour des
élections municipales placée sous le
signe de l'inédit inédit les 17
quadrangulaire élections à quatre listes
qui tiendront la vedette
cinquante cinq triangulaires quarante
sept duels sont également prévus
paradoxe huit des dix points les plus
chauds sont au nord de la loire
parmi les duels les plus en vue amiens
le havre
les deux plus grosses municipalités
communistes sont convoitées par
l'opposition udf rpr lille où pierre
mauroy tentera de repousser les assauts
du rpr metz ville symbole de l'ouverture
ou jean marie rausch a été mis en
ballottage par l'udf brest ville clé du
grand ouest que le ps voudrait enlevé au
rpr triangulaire à paris 20e le front
national jean marie le pen joue les
arbitres le grand chelem de jacques
chirac se joue là autres triangulaires
sarcelles où la division pc ps pourrait
profiter au rpr enfin trois
quadrangulaire spectaculaire strasbourg
ps et udf confrontés aux écologistes et
au front national cannes où le duel rpr
udf est arbitrée par le ps et le front
national
enfin marseille où robert vigouroux
l'exclu du ps michel pezet le candidat
officiel des socialistes jean claude
gaudin le leader de l'opposition et
gabriel domenech la tête de liste du
front national se livreront leur dernier
combat pour la mairie et pour compléter
la carte remontant au nord jusqu'à
dunkerque la seule ville du nord pas de
calais jusqu'ici encore aux mains de
l'opposition
le second tour s'annonce serré
entre le maire sortant en pente et
repère et le candidat socialiste qui est
aussi ministre du gouvernement à
dunkerque laurent boussier polémique
ragot affiches arrachées et même voiture
de candidats endommagé à dunkerque la
campagne du deuxième tour des
municipales se durcit dans cette ville
où avec 75 % de participation dimanche
dernier on a plus voté que la moyenne
nationale
les deux adversaires se disent confiants
chacun ayant au moins un motif de
satisfaction en obtenant 46 % des
suffrages michel delebarre a
considérablement amélioré le score de la
gauche qui en 83 atteignent
difficilement 31% mais le ministre des
transports qui avait déjà au premier
tour réalisé une large union sur son nom
ne peut chercher des voix aujourd'hui
que chez les abstentionnistes lorsqu'on
regarde ce qui se passait dans les
bureaux de vote dans un certain nombre
de bureaux qui sont du bureau
traditionnellement pour des forces de
gauche et de progrès où l'électorat est
très sensible ce que nous proposons il
est sûr que nous n'avons pas encore fait
le plein d'où cette semaine est une
semaine tout le monde est sur le pont et
nous faisons en sorte de mobiliser des
abstentionnistes et de convaincre un
certain nombre de personnes qui au
premier tour on choisit de voter blanc
se sont trompés dans leurs choix de
faire le choix de l'avenir de dunkerque
même si pour la première fois depuis 23
ans claude prouvoyeur n'est pas élu au
premier tour
le maire sortant est lui satisfait de
devancer son concurrent avec +2 47% des
voix et débarrassé d'une liste front
national qui n'a pu passer la barre des
10 points
il se sent en position de force michel
delbarre présenter une liste composée de
différents partis politiques et cal
droite il y avait deux listes il n'y
aura plus qu'une seule fois ci michel
d'albert a fait le plein des web wap ans
à 48 heures du scrutin les jeux sont
loin d'être faits dans la cité de jean
bart le corsaire héros tout le monde
sait que dimanche la victoire se fera à
quelques centaines de voix
les mici pas sur antenne 2 je vous le
rappelle pour calculer justement ces
voies passe aussi par 36 15 khordad vous
pouvez consulter sur votre minitel les
résultats qui vous attend
pour comprendre donc le second tour dans
tous ses détails
alors dimanche soir bien sûr soirée
électorale non-stop sur antenne 2 en
bronze y retrouvera pour ses rayons
entouré de toutes sortes de marianne
dans le décor de michel louis gants mais
ce soir vous allez nous expliquer ce qui
s'est passé hier à marseille on
s'attendait à voir enfin envers
vigouroux et jean claude gaudin sinon
face à face en tout cas côte à côte et
on n'a rien vu du tout alors sachez
christine que chacune des listes encore
en présence après le premier tour
m'avait donné son accord ce serait sous
une forme américaine j'allais dire
marseillaise
gabriel domenech pour le front national
et michel pezet pour la liste d'union de
la gauche m'avait accordé un entretien
enregistré
l'un comme l'autre avaient accepté cette
règle du jeu avec beaucoup de courtoisie
bien qu'elle leur fut défavorable robert
vigouroux avait demandé et obtenu que ce
ne soit pas un débat lui comme jean
claude gaudin serait confronté en direct
à des reportages de jacques cotta et
pascal martin et répondrait à mes
questions
l'équipe de robert vigouroux s'était
engagé très fermement ce sens devant les
représentants jean claude gaudin tout
semblait réglé mercredi soir pas
suffisamment puisque les conseils de
monsieur vigouroux parmi lesquels sans
doute bernard tapie on sollicitait le
csa conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
dénichant une recommandation écrite il
ya deux ans par la cncl sur l'égalité
des temps d'antenne en période
électorale
malgré l'accord préalable que j'avais
conclu le csa a préféré s'entretenir
s'en tenir aux textes de la cncl
raisonnant ainsi plus selon la loi du
sablier que le sel de l'information il
n'était dès lors plus possible de réunir
tous les protagonistes avec l'équipe
d'éditions spéciales je souhaitais vous
informe et contradictoirement sur
marseille les manoeuvres politiciennes
l'absence de liberté imposées par un
texte administratif ont censuré cette
émission je regrette de n'avoir pu vous
en donner les raisons d hier soir en
direct de marseille
mais ce soir c'est fait il faut dire
qu'à marseille le jeu politique et les
règles médiatique sombre parfois plus
volontiers qu'ailleurs la roumanie n'en
finit pas de souffrir de son régime et
de son président rien à manger ou
presque monuments et villages rasés à
l'envi pour sacrifier aux lubies de la
famille ceauscescu les droits de l'homme
systématiquement bafoué selon amnesty un
nouveau procès devrait avoir lieu
avant la fin du mois celui de trois
journalistes et d'un typographe coupable
de tracts hostiles au régime
la communauté internationale se mobilise
enfin la commission bruxelles décidé
d'ajourner les négociations commerciales
avec la roumanie
la france de son côté rappelle son
ambassadeur jérôme baugnies lâché par
les pays de l'est devant la commission
des droits de l'homme de l'onu qui
piquait de l'intérieur par six anciens
dirigeants du parti aujourd'hui sous
surveillance policière
le conte du quator roumain nicolae
ceaucescu vient de s'enfoncer un peu
plus dans l'isolément avec le rappel de
l'ambassadeur de france et la décision
de la commission européenne de suspendre
les négociations commerciales avec la
roumanie décision durement ressentie par
bucarest qui s'est donné comme priorité
le remboursement de la dette extérieure
les produits qui auraient pu garnir ses
étalages sont exportées contre de
précieuses devises
les roumains eux n'ont qu'à se serrer la
ceinture
c'est ce qui a provoqué la colère de
simone veil -le députés centristes au
parlement européen la situation en
roumanie est dramatique tant sur le plan
politique que sur le plan économique et
même sur le plan culturel
nous assistons à une situation que nous
n'avions pas vu dans aucun pays depuis
des décennies
en europe c'est la suppression de
villages entiers avec tout ce qu'il
représente sur le plan culturel
tout ce qu'il représente sur le plan
humain c'est la négation d'un peuple à
laquelle on est en train d'assister les
deux tiers des villages roumains doivent
selon le projet gouvernemental être
touchés par cette politique de
regroupement de villages une politique
qui a déjà provoqué en transylvanie
l'exode de milliers de paysans d'origine
hongroise ou allemandes ferme détruites
villages entiers délibérément rayé de la
carte déracinement de population où
pourrait se fixer des noyaux de révolte
la réprobation de la communauté
internationale s'exprime aussi par des
initiatives privées comme celle
d'opération villages roumains
notre but c'est de faire adopter les
treize mille villages roumains par
autant de villages d'europe de l'ouest
comme de l'est
chaque village se portera garant de la
survie de la culture du village roumain
c est glissée bâtiment est aussi surtout
ses habitants considérés à la fin des
années 60 comme le plus ouvert des pays
de l'est
la roumanie est devenue vingt ans après
le plus hermétique aux droits de l'homme
et ce soir le gouvernement britannique a
une nouvelle fois dénoncé dans un
communiqué la répression dans ce pays un
gouvernement britannique bien embarrassé
par le travail de sa propre presse les
journaux là bas continuent en effet
d'enquêté sur la sphère lockerbie ou
plutôt l'explosion en plein vol
au-dessus de ce petit village écossais
d'aberdeen de la panam en décembre
dernier les services britanniques
connaîtrait l'identité de l'auteur de
l'attentât
c'est ce qu'affirment certains journaux
mais surtout le gouvernement n'aurait
pas suffisamment tenu compte des
investissements qui lui étaient
parvenues de londres philippe harrouard
en fait on s'aperçoit que beaucoup de
gens savaient beaucoup de choses en
secret le 22 novembre un mois avant la
catastrophe le ministère britannique des
transports avait prévenu les compagnies
aériennes et les aéroports qu'un
attentat les se produire sur un vol de
la panam les autorités américaines et
allemandes avaient déjà averti après la
découverte d'une cache d'armes
en allemagne la police avait même
spécifié que la bombe serait dissimulé
dans une radio k7
le 19 décembre deux joueurs dans
l'attentât le ministère britannique des
transports envoie une photo de la bombe
aux compagnies aériennes et aux
aéroports par la poste le courrier à
cause des encombrements de noël mettra
un mois arrivait trop tard
d'où les reproches de panaméricains le
ministre pose shannon réplique que la
compagnie américaine
deux clans façon avait déjà été averti
plusieurs fois auparavant
la lettre ne contenait aucune autre
information complémentaire
on comprend l'amertume des familles des
victimes qui se demandent pourquoi avec
toutes ces données connues par les
gouvernements les services secrets les
compagnies aériennes les aéroports
le ou les terroristes ont pu quand même
placé leur bombe à bord de l'avion ce
matin certains journaux ont annoncé
l'arrestation en allemagne des
responsables de l'attentât
démenti catégorique des enquêteurs qui
poursuivent leur travail très lentement
ont ils prévenu accident spectaculaire
et meurtrier en italie à pavie la tour
romane
11ème siècle super ben brik cette tour
s'est effondrée ce matin at-on signer
quatre morts 17 blessés bilan toujours
provisoire de l'effondrement de la tour
civique à un édifice de style roman de
près de 1000 ans d'âge et au de 78 m les
éboulis ont recouvert un kiosque à
journaux et plusieurs magasins aux
alentours pour les pompiers qui ont déjà
dégagé deux survivants en fin d'après
midi les recherches continuent selon les
spécialistes des monuments historiques
ce genre d'accident est impossible à
prévoir
effondrement d'une passerelle métallique
à alger dans le quartier d'el harrach
bilan provisoire quatre morts et près de
200 blessés
la construction a cédé sous le poids
dépassant 3 à 400 personnes précipiter
dans les eaux de l'oued chaque vendredi
jour de marché
plusieurs milliers de personnes
empruntent cette vieille passerelle
décidément la france ne réussit pas à
[ __ ] les adds le voilà arrêté à
villeneuve loubet déjà en 84 on avait
capturé dans 16ème arrondissement de la
capitale
cruel les nerfs fragiles on surnomme le
fou depuis novembre dernier zatzal un
des chefs de la camorra napolitaine et
le septième de l'organisation à être
interpellé par les policiers français
cette fois peut-être
restera-t-il en prison plus longtemps
que d'habitude et goscinny a le bon
accent explosion d'une voiture piégée ce
matin à beyrouth dans la banlieue
chrétienne 12 morts 140 blessés et
surtout la crainte est plutôt la crainte
encore d'un nouvelle confrontation
militaire reprise aujourd'hui à nanterre
du procès du commissaire jobic
l'ambiance était plus sereine que ces
derniers jours rémy roche l'heure de
vérité qui approche pour yves jobic il
sort de la salle d'audience après avoir
entendu tout l'après midi les avocats de
la partie civile plaidé sa culpabilité
comment j'avais les béjaouis elles m'ont
parole du pessimiste ils sont trois et
c'est un dossier qu'il connaisse au
millimètre qu'ils vont disséquer tour à
tour pendant quatre heures pour redire
finalement leur confiance à la justice
qu'ils ont vu durement attaqué pendant
le procès vous condamnerez jobic lens
william bourdon pour affirmer
l'indépendance de la justice
et parce qu'il ya des charges celle que
va rappeler dans le détail francis
terquem des charges dit il que n'a pu
masquer la formidable machine qui s'est
mise en route depuis le début de
l'instruction pour tenter de disculper
le commissaire jobic des charges et des
victimes qui ont fait preuve d'un
courage exemplaire il est déjà très
difficile je pense pour une prostituée
de mettre en cause son proxénète le
mettre en cause lorsque elle estime que
le proxénète est un policier
elle est toute la puissance toute la
force qui a derrière la police et en
espèces le policier qui est prévenu je
crois que c'est la preuve d'un courage
formidable m terquem de les terminer par
ces mots lorsque la police respecte la
justice qu'elle se tient à sa place au
service du citoyen cela porte un très
beau nom la république et il faut que
son procureur
la défendent fermement le procureur dont
le réquisitoire sera précisément écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention
lundi matin vive la petite reine le
vélocipède tient salon à paris à la
porte de versailles à partir
d'aujourd'hui le vélo sous toutes ses
formes se porte bien très bien même
comme l'a constaté alain de risque
vous avez toujours cru qu'une bicyclette
avait au moins deux roues de fourche une
chaîne un guidon pas du tout regardé une
moitié de fourche est finie les doigts
tout noir quand vous crevé à l'arrière
la chaîne reste sur le cadre au
démontage ce vélo a descendu 10080 une
marche en huit heures sans casser cette
fois deux chaînes au lieu d'une finis
les temps morts le pédalier décalé
entraîné deux chaînes l'une est toujours
sous tension vous n'avez plus que 3
secondes pour réfléchir aux avantages du
système avant de passer aux vélos
suivant stop maintenant admirer le vélo
de l'année le tracker max max comme max
innovation maxi technologie maxi
efficacité ça doit être vrai puisqu'il
est vélo de l'année à un détail maxi
pris douze mille francs nous avons voulu
nous y retrouver entre mountain bike
city bag freestyle et bicross voici ce
que cela donne dans la bouche d'un
spécialiste
je commencerai par festive parce que
c'est ce que peut faire c'est super
c'est mon vélo 2000 les pièces c'est
super bref le vélo de papa au grenier
sauf si papa transport bébé ou bien si
papa et de la police nous avons vu dans
les rues de la ville
des vestiges d'une époque dépasser deux
hommes roulant sur des bicyclettes
normal nous avons même trouvé une petite
société de coursiers qui a abandonné le
vélomoteur au profit de la bicyclette
il paraît que ça plaît bien nos clients
nous on arrive avec un look un petit peu
fun sympa dynamique et souvent ça
intéresse nos clients tout à fait si
vous avez peur d'avoir l'air bête pour
vélo et bien achetez donc cet élégant
qu'a dit quand vos amis auront le dos
tourné
transformer le vite en bicyclette
il faut toujours du muscle de meilleures
nouvelles ce soir de l'état de santé de
philippe streiff le pilote de formule 1
gravement accidentée lors des excès les
essais du grand prix du brésil
philippe streiff à pouvoir être
rapatriés dans les prochains jours
ultime séance d'entraînement ce matin à
clairefontaine pour le quinze de france
avant sa rencontre avec les cosses
demain après midi au parc des princes
une équipe pour finn et par jacques
fouroux et dans ses lignes des anciens
toujours jeunes gens ma mère jacques
fouroux compte beaucoup sur sa vieille
garde pour faire face demain à l'échos
il n'a pas hésité à maintenir les
anciens comme jean condom le deuxième
ligne et philippe dintrans le talonneur
jean condom devenu avec 54 sélections le
plus titre à son poste du rugby français
jacques fouroux n'a pas hésité aussi à
rappeler jean pierre garuet 36 ans au
poste de pilier
il a toujours su à force de persuasion
convaincre ses troupes de tout et du
contraire
au point de faire jouer lachenaie a
banni re 2e lille 1 pour prendre des
balles en touche alors que son poste
habituel et celui le troisième ligne
aile mais jacques fouroux avec laurent
rodriguez sans oubliant d'art sous leurs
yeux et quelques autres vie avec ce
groupe une bien belle aventure de la
coupe du monde à quatre victoires dans
le tournoi
c'est une page d'histoire qui ne se
tournent pas aisément j'ai quand même vu
partir un garçon si prestigieux
extraordinaire que roland bertranne
paparemborde m bernard voyer dospital
est en montre jean luc joinel francis
haget
et puis le rugby doit continuer je crois
que c'est la règle
mais je crois que le moins de respect
qu'on doit cette équipe est un joueur
qui la composent ces deux quand même se
souvenir des belles heures qu'on vient
de vivre avec eux et grâce aux joueurs
qui sont eux qui jouent
samedi à 15 heures un énorme paquet de
souvenirs sans surgir en boucle sur la
pelouse du parc des princes
la marseillaise aura dans le coeur de
quelques-uns une résonance particulière
la dernière peut-être avant l'explosion
hugo demain à 15 heures rendez-vous en
direct sur antenne 2 bien sûr pour la
rencontre france ecosse de la pelouse à
la scène changeant de style pour aller à
la comédie française antoine vitez
administrateurs et metteur en scène
célèbre à sa manière le bicentenaire à
sa manière au plus tôt à la manière de
beaumarchais en nous offrant à partir de
demain le mariage de figaro georges les
goûts et jean louis doucet ont pu
soulever un coin du rideau rouge huit
ans avant la révolution
louis saez interdit le mariage de figaro
mais vos marchés déplorent qu'il ne
s'agit là que de la plus badine des
intrigues quoi figaro veut empêcher sa
future femme domestique comme lui
d'échapper au droit de cuissage
si tu venais en chasser sur l'appli nos
jardins je mettrai à cergy jérôme était
mon seigneur tu essaies tout jeune
créature depuis votre sagesse à
préserver l'honneur reçoivent
publiquement de votre main l'association
pour une autre plume et de rubans
l'autre témoin de la pureté vos
attentions
en contrepoint la conteste se laisse
chanter la romance par chérubins bel
imbroglio de théâtre mais là n'est pas
le seul mérite de la pièce beaumarchés y
évoque la lutte des classes et se montre
violent envers la justice et la police
oui si l'on sait bien que si le fonds
dépensés aparté auprès de la forme et le
patrimoine des tribunaux
jouer bien ou mal un personnage pour
répandre des espions y pense ce n'est
des vers à le lire des cachets
intercepter les frais cachés dans leur
mire la pauvreté des moyens par
l'importante d orsay voilà toute la
politique use mal plus que la liberté
plus que la fraternité de bahia
évidemment fondée sur l'égalité sur le
fait qu' il n'y a pas de naissance dans
ce sens là qu'on peut dire qu il
préfigurait les droits de l'homme nasa
tout à fais ça c'est ma maison ça c'est
vraiment lui ces salles qui aiment
religionnaires dans cette oeuvre ces
révolutionnaires contexte
révolutionnaire en jouant au bridge à
néant en s'amusant
mais c'est profondément leur iphone via
chamailler c'est pesé sur le collier
sans relâche comme les malheureux
chevaux de la remonte des fleuves qui ne
repose pas même quand il s'arrête et qui
fument toujours quoi qu'ils cessent de
marché nous attendons
si vous ne connaissez pas le musée de la
marine au palais de chaillot et si vous
êtes à paris a décidé ce week-end vous y
verrez une très belle exposition qui
raconte une double aventure celle du mot
issus qui sombra il ya quatre siècles au
large du gabon est celle d'une véritable
pêche au trésor philippe dumez au large
du cap lopez au gabon par 15 mètres de
fond les vestiges exceptionnels d'un
galion englouti en 1609 à son retour de
chine le mauricien s'est échoué sur un
banc de sable avec toute sa cargaison
entre autres des échantillons de
porcelaine chinoise ramené pour étudier
les possibilités de commerce
toutes ces pièces on les retrouve
exposée au musée de la marine avec des
canons bien sûr à la fois beau et rare
par leur diversité
à l'époque la compagnie hollandaise des
indes orientales se tailler des parts de
marché à coups de canon contre les
portugais les anglais ou les français au
xviie siècle cette compagnie faisait
construire en moyenne 500 galion parents
est utilisé plus de 30 milles marins
pour son commerce avec la chine le japon
ou l'indonésie
malgré le nombre impressionnant de ses
bâtiments
le mauricien c'est un des rares que l'on
ait retrouvé et c'est un pur hasard
puisque c'est la société elf qui en
cherchant du pétrole à 2000 mètres des
côtes est tombé sur ce trésor history un
trésor chargé aussi de la mort des
marins parti pour l'aventuré ou la
conquête du monde
les conditions d'existence à bord de ces
navires de 40 à 45 mètres de long était
souvent inhumaines et les naufrages très
fréquents
musée de la marine donc à paris dans un
instant laurent cabrol va vous parler du
temps pour demain tout à l'heure 22h50
dernier journal avec philippe lefait et
bien sûr pour le week end sur antenne 2
vous avez rendez vous pour vous informer
avec daniel via lyon philippe gassot et
bernard up pour la scène anglaise très
bon week end à lundi